Hey
everybody,
so a lot of people out there have been
asking me about my writing and whether
or not there's something of mine that
you can read.
Well,
today I'm going to be releasing my first
book,
Big City,
which I wrote about a year ago on
gumroad.com,
a digital copy for $3.
Now I hope that you think that that's
fair.
I put a lot of work into this and I
don't think it's so much money where you
know if you don't like the book,
you feel that you've wasted it.
Obviously though,
I hope that you do like it.
You can find the link for the full text
in the dupe later today.
I'm going to be reading the first part
of it for you firstly because I love to
read and listen to fiction.
Secondly,
because it'll give you guys a chance to
see what the book will be like.
Now,
just a few words here before I get
started.
In the way of a summary,
imagine that you're reading the back
flap here in the bookstore.
As the title suggests,
the story is about a big city and
impossibly big city of vast urban sprawl
that goes on and on in every direction
of city you couldn't possibly see all of
in a lifetime and one in which people
get so easily lost in the confusion of
streets and high rises and bars and
moving lights.
It's a science fiction setting,
certainly influenced by cyber punk,
but the story is about eight people who
are trying to live and survive in this
chaotic mess of a place and who are all
experiencing this very unique and
strange phenomenon called seeing the
whole thing.
Now there is a secret buried in the
story about what the city is,
what seeing the whole thing means about
what they're all doing there,
but of course you have to read the whole
thing to find out what that what that
is.
Okay,
so go to a dark place,
getting them,
getting the mood.
Here's the first part of big city called
Mac ludgate.
Mac ludgate returned from the
[inaudible] region,
also called coat Malai,
province and sector 22 way without a
tatter of currency to his name.
He had begun his sojourn to that
blistery junction of try district
gambling,
not six months before dreaming of a
streak,
but all he got was a dark new
appreciation for settling debts.
He picked the scab on his forehead and
thought this is ready to fall off as the
automated female voice recording spat
out the name of his home district now
entering loan and district Taj Zhou
Province municipal sector 25.
A change here for all silverline.
Tram stores will open on my right and
again in three alternate languages,
but he was wrong about the scab.
It bled.
Here were the things Mac knew as he
stepped from the tram into loan n one,
he could stay at Shelly's for as long as
he liked to.
The ice on most of his bets was covered.
He had little to worry about in the way
of rancorous businessmen.
Three,
he was guaranteed at least one free meal
everyday at his uncle Warren's
restaurant on the corner of 15th and
Catskill Street,
and four,
there was every chance that Mr Hoy econ
would hire him back to his old position
at lm and p.
So long as Hoy con didn't know that mack
was living with his daughter,
he nestled himself into the cocoon of
these near certainties and use them as a
coat against the unseasonable.
Cold
loan and station was empty and they'll
mac could not recall the time when it
was otherwise.
The space provoked in him,
the feeling of being only recently
abandoned by a host of people,
strange that anyone would gather here he
said to himself as a rush of hot air,
move through the terminal and at once
vivified his suspicions with paralyzing
emphasis,
hints of Phantom Card players,
eyes receding into their sockets.
Rhinestone whores,
toothless,
always smiling,
the flotsam of degeneracy behind every
corner.
He was sure of it.
Mac blinked rapidly to dispel these
apparitions,
but captured instead the after images of
dusty fluorescents that spread light
through the station all thin and dry,
more ghosts.
They had followed him here.
Nerves short circuited.
Oh God.
Six months of uppers withdraw.
His heart raced away and these silly
tricks of the night,
so affected Max eggshell spirit that he
ran from loan and station and a boyish
frenzy fleeing a host of illusory
terrorists.
Shelly grave lived on the east side of
loan end in a triplex behind Jefferson
Park,
near Uncle Warren's restaurant on 15th
have a building that small was a rare
commodity and loan n and rare is still.
She and her daughter Lisa occupied the
whole first floor.
Most of that district's population was
crammed into the row of towering
apartment blocks that lined the far edge
of town,
but shelly had gotten years ago at a low
fixed rent before prices rose
drastically.
District wide fluctuations of that kind
were frequent and all sectors of the
city like when through skyscraper and
streets and unexplainable as a matter of
course.
Why this particular rent stayed fixed is
easy enough to puzzle out if you know
Shelly Mac
knocked on her door,
hasn't hesitantly in a way a man does
when he is merely trying to prove to
himself that he was there and did that
thing.
Really.
He was of two minds,
he needed rest and warm sometime for his
nerves to settle.
This was clear from the episode at the
Tram Station,
but being here bashfully,
knocking like a teenager,
Matt could not help but recognize a
scene from a story played over and over.
It annoyed him to know what shelly would
say when she opened the door,
how he would respond,
where the night would go,
what the next day would bring and so
forth.
He wanted desperately to deviate from
this plot,
but it was hopeless.
His character always wanted to deviate
in the scene to do something impetuous
or dangerous or just plain wrong,
but never did.
So shelly opened the door and the story
played on,
look,
a millionaire.
Yeah,
and it's all yours.
He pushed fire.
What's that smell?
Does that fish?
Where did you get fish from?
So you expect to come in and what?
She had already botched the practice
speech.
Jump in bed with this is in your world.
I'm walking around and Mac,
listen to me.
I give my arm for a dose of Xeno.
Got Any,
but he had already spotted traces on the
coffee table,
tiny blue speck,
sprinkled over the smiles of magazine
cover girls and grocery store coupons.
He turned over an issue of celebrity
health with the famous actress Jocelyn
Marquette,
posing candidly on the cover and there
it was.
The feebly hid porcelain jar.
No data piece.
Spade my,
her daughter Lisa in school.
Bingo Mac.
Join me,
will you?
We can yell at each other tomorrow.
I'm deadbeat.
He dropped a small blue tablet into his
pipe.
One thing he had not lost in Cotana and
ground it down with the bud of the pen.
One long drag and stupidity crashed over
his mind.
Simplicity.
Yes.
The end of all thought.
He passed the pipe to shelly who seemed
to have given up her protests at site of
the drug.
She was thinking,
well,
finish this tomorrow and took a drag for
herself,
a sweet repos.
She nestled herself into the crook of
his arm and together they sank into the
red round cushions of the couch.
Nothing moved.
The television was tuned to one of those
channels which only plays music probably
because shelly couldn't afford a full
entertainment package.
The noise was faint,
but Mac caught enough to discern which
channel it was he needed to have heard
it.
Though shelly only ever played one
station this late at night,
particularly when she was dosing city
reflections.
Istation,
unlike any other,
it's sole purpose was to catch old
frequencies that had been broadcast and
set bouncing into the city sound maze of
a trillion buildings.
You might hear something on reflections
that had been played a thousand years
ago in a province you would never know
the name of,
but who could say after all that
bounding and rebounding,
if what you were hearing was the music
as it was originally recorded,
who could say if it was even music,
it might just a well has been,
have been modulated.
Police sirens or distressing those maybe
the arrhythmic calculations of an
ancient supercomputer.
It gave people a sense of communion
anyway.
It helps them forget the size of the
city or else feel the magnitude and its
full capacity.
Mack was proud that his district set the
places he had heard of had invented
something like city reflections.
He wondered if other places had it to
the music,
pulsed over the room,
cautiously like a vessel signaling.
It's approach a port in a low fog,
and they allowed that strange melody to
fuse it's essence with their own,
both of them being so dissatisfied at
that moment with the state of being
required by human mind.
Molecules mingled with wavelengths were
twisted and strewn mislaid shuffled
around,
transmuted and exchanged,
and if afterward only the music remained
so what?
The drug was in full effect.
Mac kept raising the volume because his
ears kept adjusting and he wanted it to
be loud.
What was he trying to death and what?
Scab?
Light question still itched at him under
all that noise?
Yes.
His secret.
Wish for shelly not to answer,
he couldn't have been in his right mind.
This was exactly what he wanted and
being here with her weight on him.
Six months of uppers and the knife's
edge stress knife's edge stress of
[inaudible] card rooms had set a system
on a dangerous tempo.
What was the motive for going to that
whole?
He couldn't remember what we didn't want
to,
but loan end did that to you.
It was the kind of place that magnetized
it's population.
Even the slightest relaxation of purpose
would be enough to persuade an Erin
traveler that it was time he ought to go
home and it is sometimes said that
wherever alone inborn folk go in their
lives,
no matter the distance or duration,
they always die in loan end.
Shelly's daughter Lisa awoken by the
music that could not be loud enough,
trudged into the living room and found
her mother completely stoned on the
couch with a man of whom she had only
the faintest recollection.
Lisa knew very little about drugs,
but enough to knew,
know what it looked like when you were
on them.
Shelly seeing Lisa and her peach colored
pajamas clutching a teddy bear that had
been patched and repatch dozens of
times,
shot up from the couch and tried to act
authoritative.
Lisa,
why are you up?
Do you want some water or do you need
anything?
I don't mean to yell at you.
The music was loud.
She said I couldn't sleep.
Her eyes were fixed on Mac,
who smile,
suggested friendliness,
but she had been fooled by looks before
she chose to distrust him.
Haley said,
remember me?
All she said was,
can you turn it down please?
And the little girl walked back to her
room fainting all the disappointment of
a mother.
Mac.
You asked,
turn it down.
And he did.
Oh,
this is a disaster.
Why don't I let you ruin everything?
Fuck,
fuck.
She knocked the porcelain jar off the
coffee table and the little blue tablet
spilled and we're lost in the shaggy
fibers of the carpet in that very
moment,
shelley grave swore off Zena friend to
forever.
So mortified to what she thought her
daughter thought she was.
But this was her character's nightly
promise.
And like the other was never to be kept.
Please go.
She whispered and left him there.
Instinctively mack went for the tablets
that had been strewn in the Sylvan Rug,
uh,
tasked that prove more difficult than it
should have.
The drugs still had a strong hold over
him now instead of no thought ideas came
swarming into his head like beads
converging again and again on the same
conclusion.
My reality is on a loop,
never had he felt more sure about
something than this.
He rewound the day in his head and
played it over.
He did the same with the previous six
months and before repeated occurrences
of the same night this night,
laid out like sardines in a tin and it
all seems so pathetic.
The did he have no control over this sad
circle of events.
He looked down at the handful of blue
tablets and new at once that they were
the root cause of his problems.
He heard it to the kitchen,
desperate to maintain control over his
mind before the other part,
the stone sucker part could reclaim it.
He lifted up the dirty plates in the
sink and drop the pills into the
disposal.
Yes,
cut off the supply.
Eliminate the opportunity for desire to
prey on the weaker self.
No indulgence.
He exhaled and out came everything bad,
overcooked fish wafted from the nearby
stovetop.
Mac.
Wondered again,
where did Shelly get fish from?
He was sure that she didn't have the
money for food.
That rare sense memory set off a tiny
projector in his head,
a tangled dream of gatherings at his
uncle Warren's restaurant on catskill
street.
Birthdays,
anniversaries is six.
His sister's graduation from the
University of Praxis,
that dreadful resection after his
mother's funeral when he drank too much
and actually accidentally told Mr Hoy
con that he was fucking his daughter.
She's a tigress bruce.
Real rough,
but watch out for those nails as Shell
Hoy con fired him on the spot only to
rehire him a week later,
after many apologies and his promise
that he would break it off with shelly
forever blaring yellow light the sun.
No passing district police or was
yellow.
The municipality detail so fucking hard
to keep track.
Koten was lawless.
Free from that bewildering rainbow of
authority.
The light there was always the same
color,
harsh white,
raining like a God over octagonal
octagonal card tables,
concealing the eyes of your opponents
and turning the heads of emaciated
amateurs like Mac into small,
chalky skulls.
It was also deliberately organize to
throw you off balance by who the hell
you knew that going in.
At least there you can really lose
yourself at least there.
You could piss in the streets,
whichever authority it was.
The light broke.
His trans and Mac was suddenly overcome
with a wild hunger.
He scraped the burnt leftover fish from
the skillet and slapped it onto a dirty
plate in the cupboard.
There was a bottle of Bourbon.
Another odd thing to find at Shelly's.
He ate slowly like a beast,
staving off the urge to devour it's
prize in one great bite.
Fish after all was nothing to sneeze at
and Bourbon,
the life of a king.
His uncle love Berman always had a glass
with dinner.
Maybe she got the gift from Warren,
uh,
the fish for more and as a gift.
But,
and the truth was there
on his plate in his glass,
mocking him.
The clever bitch fish every night if she
wanted it,
free alcohol all in exchange for
turbulent sex and the occasional dose of
Xeno.
He rushed at the thought of all that
full acid skin perspiring,
greasy.
And what did they say about him in bed
afterwards?
That he was a joke,
making a fool of himself.
Could they guess when he'd returned a
broken record?
That boy he heard it loud and clear in
the kitchen.
Silence no more.
He scrambled into Shelly's bedroom,
found her curled up in a ball under the
covers and in one vicious motion kicked
her from the bed.
But the wait was wrong.
He felt it immediately to light.
The small body crashed into the far
wall.
At first,
the little girl scream came as if from
far away and then.
And then it was right there,
cleaving him into shelly found her
daughter strewn on the floor like a
ragdoll.
The girl's neck had hit the protruding
window sill and this sent her into
severe convulsions of bent nerve.
Probably appendages thrashed against the
pho wood paneling.
Quick sonorous studs,
Lisa,
she nailed over her daughter.
Completely helpless.
You weren't supposed to touch a seizing
person,
right?
She couldn't remember.
Mack was in shock.
His leg,
his legs moved as if by another brain
slowly out of the room.
His body was taking the necessary steps
to extricate itself from the
repercussions of this horrible accident
and accident.
That's what it was.
Could he be blamed for it?
Really?
Images spilled into his head randomly.
Uncle Warren drinking bourbon from a
perspiring glass.
The gruff sniggers have better gambler.
Something strange.
The strap,
the scratch on his mothers coffin.
How did it get there?
Oh yes,
yes.
There was a rock hidden in the shovel of
dirt.
He was supposed to dump over the casket
at drew,
a line directly above her knees or her
shoulders.
He couldn't recall what side the head
was on,
and Lisa twitching like a broken doll.
He found himself in the kitchen again,
standing over the sink.
Lisa seizure was only a faint tapping in
the room.
Beyond Dalen the disposal.
He could see the small pile of blue
tablets.
Why had he gotten rid of the Xeno?
Think of the money.
He was throwing away stupid to throw
away all that money.
He would need it now.
He reached down the tapping ceased
silence and then city reflection boomed
from the living room.
Television.
Mac turned around to see who had turned
it on,
but nobody was there.
A contract auto voice called out strange
lyrics,
the creaking of the tented sky,
the ticking of eternity.
I saw and heard a new atlast the how and
why,
of all things past and present and
forevermore.
The universe,
cliff to the core,
lay open to my probing sense and augury.
That's what it felt like.
Had he succeeded in derailing the
looping story.
Yes.
Mac turned around to the sink and was
startled to see shelley there standing
before him.
Her face as cold as the night.
I'm sorry,
he said or did she say it?
Her finger was flushed on a light
switch,
but he observed no light turn on or off.
When he flipped it,
moisture on his cheek.
Mack looked down to see his hand being
torn apart by blades,
so swift and sharp that at first he felt
no pain and then the pain came and Mac
ludgate saw the whole thing.